girls look at your shoes first man I
actually look at your shoes first
okay but that doesn't make you a girl
makes you a sneaker kingpin we're in
Brooklyn New York talking about the five
sneakers every man should own you're on
Instagram you're online you're in a
store you see a pair of sneakers you
love and you just buy them without
thinking about it I'm here with Ronnie
fog of kif this is how to put together
an intentional sneaker collection
there's a reason we're starting with
running sneakers today why is that sort
of one of the one of the cornerstones of
a man's sneaker collection I think
running has become this lifestyle
product it became one of those styles of
sneakers that you could wear everywhere
I chose this a New Balance 574 fresh
foam they took the original og colorway
of the 574 and they put their spin on it
they added some burgundy leather to the
heel I was at the podiatrist recently
I'm a big dude my feet hurt hey and he
was like a six a six a six you have a
long history with Asics I immediately
came to this I also like red that's the
first shoe that I ever worked on the
waterproof suede it's like suede without
the paranoia kind of a crazy tongue
situation going on here the og split
tongue both colors are super bright and
saturated so if you see me jogging by
you really slowly I got him here at Kidd
to get [ __ ] to the register can go you
better pay for that [ __ ] man
Ronni you need a pair of basketball
shoes even if you never whoo yes for
sure you know people don't want to see
wearing the same shoes every day yeah
and you need to have a variety of
different lifestyle shoes to wear with
different outfits the Jordan one
pinnacle veg ten veg tan you're gonna
have to explain that to the people the
leather is in its natural state and it
only gets better with age right that
Jordan one right there is hard to
compete with but the 1994 Charles
Barkley I picked these because I had him
when I was a kid a round mound of
rebound basketball shoes this is like
arguably the most important category at
all of sneaker culture it's also
important category in your sneaker
closet one time you need a pair of
sneakers just right for the occasion is
when you're traveling if you're doing
the twelve hole Doc Martens through the
airport you're taking a pail oh man
stamped Puma collaboration it's called
the trinom excel for me I like the bass
best because when you travel this goes
basically with any color that you wear I
think I'm gonna go with something it
does have laces but you can just keep it
loose and get them right onto right off
let's see it so a kiss right now the
Presto is a royal blue it's one of the
most comfortable Nike shoes for any of
the shoes that I have ever owned like
he's doing these his ID right now so I
could actually go online I probably
would go online and make my own color
it's fall the weather's getting bad and
frankly nobody has a better boot
selection than Ronnie and KITT and I
just couldn't resist so we're gonna pick
a boot - Ronnie really excited for this
brand it's a brand out of Italy called
for a cop they can only make 24 pairs
per day only can be made by hand it's
not like everybody on your block is
gonna be wearing exactly that's the
first thing and the second thing is
you'll probably had the best meet boot
on the block you don't have to be like
ginger with and you knows where no you
could beat these up right oh ho what's
more classic than a pair of pins fall of
2015 you can probably find me
god-willing on I'm 82 years old wearing
these wrong with the black belt - yeah
this is GQ sometimes we got to wear a
suit I can help you with that
there's right and wrong ways to wear our
sneaker with a suit right and there are
new ways to do it too and there are new
ways to do it I'm going right here
sticking with all black team Chuck
Taylors this is like gonna take you to
that strokes kind of rocked out will
read Ramones it's definitely an
old-school approach right it is this
would look great with a suit so great
choice all right Ronnie's gonna take us
through a kind of new way to rock a rock
seekers with a suit when I do have to
wear a suit I'm always thinking about
what that Footwear element can be and
for me I think individuality is key if
you're wearing a black suit and you're
wearing this shoe you're just doing
something right yeah it's very sleek
it's mostly neoprene nobody's gonna
mistake you for like you know a waiter
or security guard all right guys so
that's it the complete sneaker wardrobe
we got the runner the basketball shoe
the travel shoe the boot and the sneaker
with a suit and guys please let us know
how we did in the comment section
alright and also if you have any style
questions let us know and we'll see what
we can do see you next week